voici quatre ans quatre ans que marion
fraysse a mis fin à ses jours par
pendaison suite à du harcèlement
scolaire
depuis sa mère nora se bat avec son
association marion les mains tendues
elle se déplace dans tous les
établissements pour sensibiliser les
parents sur ce fléau et diffuse aux
familles un téléfilm qui retrace le
parcours tragique de sa fille
souvent les gens sont démunis sont pas
tous concernés mais sont tous touchés
par le phénomène
certains vous diront ah c'est pas mon
enfant mais moi même je l' ai vécu où
j'ai été borderline nous devons dire je
suis grand parents commencent à réagir
face aux écrans géants un faisceau
d'indicés parce que vous croyez qu'ils
se passent telle ou telle chose il faut
lever les doutes
comment porter plainte qui contacter
c'est quoi le harcèlement voilà c'est
mettre des mots sur un phénomène qui
aujourd'hui
un truc un élève sur dix en france selon
les statistiques quatre adolescents se
suiciderait chaque année à cause du
cyber harcèlement 61 % des élèves
harcelés disent avoir des idées de
suicide un fléau qui concerne autant les
parents que les enfants prendre compte
s'il ya un problème pas parce que des
fois l'enfant dit rien moi je les suis
de trois ans mère de trois ans après que
mon fils était tapé embêtait à l'école
donc ce qu'ils voyaient une psychologue
pour autre chose et il a fait un dessin
mon c'est comme ça qu'on l'a su duc
voilà j'attends de voir un petit peu le
parcours des familles qui sont touchées
par le harcèlement et essayer de
comprendre s'il y aurait pas quelque
chose pour pour prévenir du harcèlement
essayer de trouver des remèdes avant le
suicide
22% des enfants harcelés n'en parle à
personne pour lutter contre ce fléau le
gouvernement a mis un site en place non
au harcèlement point education.gouv.fr
vous pouvez aussi contacter des
professionnels aux 30 20